hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
mord vorstellung und zwar stelle ich
euch heute pinguine vor als ich stelle
euch nicht vor
wieso läuft sie vor mir weg stellt ihr
euch natürlich nicht vor ihr kennt
glaube ich was dieser komme ich nehme
etwas vorweg man kann sich pinguin
zähmen und das hier ist mein gezähmter
pinguin und der läuft einfach von mir
weg war wenn ich jetzt hier hin laufen
rein theoretisch müsste der sich acht
bläser wieder der kleine spatz dies ist
eine minecraft modifikation für 1.7
punkt 10 glaube ich forsche cetera pp
die pinguine hinzufügt also wir können
hier oben beispielsweise einfach mal
penguin eingeben dann seht ihr diese
ganze sache werden hinzugefügt dass hier
sind nämlich 9
98 17 17 pinguine meine ich hier gibt es
ganz viele verschiedene weise den king
pinguin kann ich euch mal als beispiel
einfach zeigen weil ich nicht jeden mit
euch durchgehend will ich möchte aus als
die mutter selber runterladen das heißt
da könnt ihr selber mal schauen wie das
ganze ist der link ist irgendwo in der
beschreibung wenn ich beispielsweise
hier mal so einen kleinen blauen
pinguins baumann kann ich auch mal okay
was macht er für sound das hier ist dann
beispielsweise der king pinguin dass es
hat dieser kleine blaue und das süße ist
wenn ich beispielsweise einen von den
angreifer kriegen alle rote augen und
attackieren mich und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise in den games 04 schon die
können wir ganz schön böse werden du
bist jetzt noch einer übrig der mich
boxen möchte und ihr seht jetzt wenn ich
diesen kleinen kollegen getötet
seht ihr schon der drop einigen kleine
sachen die jetzt auf mich zu geflogen
sind und zwar einen blue tango ins kinn
und dieser pinguins kind beziehungsweise
ich kann auch mal eben zu dem anderen
pinguin auf ihr laub und den irgendwie
versuchen zu töten
die esa oder ist wieder mal ein
gezähmter pinguin nicht den jetzt
getötete tier der wird auch rot und will
mich auch attackieren aber gibt wie zum
beispiel das ist natürlich sehr geil das
ist einfach da und die geben mir auf
jeden fall seine art ich sag mal so wie
kollegah ist das in etwa das ist halt
diese pinguin haut was ich weiß gar
nicht ob kino in unter naturschutz
stehen oder ob das feld oder diese
dieser dieses dieses dieses was die halt
diese körperoberfläche ob die für ihn
was verwendet wird in der mode ich liebe
auf jeden fall pinguin und deswegen
stelle ich die modifikation vor guckt
mal mit dem hirn den habe ich mir gerade
schon gezielt gebt euch einfach mal das
hier guck mal ich kann
er bleibt stehen der lulu aber naja wir
wollen uns natürlich um die mod
beschäftigen und zwar bekomme ich diese
penguin skins und mit diesem penguin
skins kann ich mir andere sachen kräften
wie beispielsweise
oder irgendwen penguin pants oder andere
sachen und diese rüstung benötige ich um
es mit den special pinguins aufzunehmen
sagen jetzt mein beispielsweise hier
habe ich sonst von flame pinguinen einen
ninja penguin und einen cloud penguin
und diese drei haben besondere
eigenschaften und groppen hier auch
besondere dinge die ich für besondere
andere dinge verwenden kann
allerdings zeige ich euch erst mal wenn
ich jetzt hier beispielsweise den team
den ich habe ist der größte pinguin dem
spiel
das ist der empirie ob pinguin oder m
doch mp mp rohr pinguin und er ist
eigentlich erstmal so also ohne diese
halskette und meine hat ja schon so eine
steife dran und ich kann ihn einfach so
ein bisschen das ist wichtig dass ihr of
fish nehmen weil gebratenen fisch wollen
die in wenig kann ich ihn einfach mit
füttern und dann sitzt er sich so hin
und denkt sich so ihr euch bin jetzt ein
pinguin aber die helfen mir nicht im
kampf gegen andere mops also eigentlich
kommt mal wenn ich jetzt
ich bin mit meinen pinguins am schlüssel
ich greifen und die interessiert das
einfach nicht
übrigens machen die extrem ekelhafte
geräusch jedenfalls kommen jetzt mal zu
den drei besonderen arten der pinguin
und zwar gibt es einmal den cloud
pinguin also den wolken pinguin das
finde ich es mit einer der schönsten
pinguin und erinnert mich immer an
sonnen an sonnen die heißt es pro von
arktos ein bisschen weil recht dieses
programm greift respawn nur im kältesten
biom und so wenn ich den angreifer
fliegt der weg und erinnert mich so an
sorgt das oder wies diese andere noch
mal ließen mich legria sondern so zwei
verschiedene ein rotes und ein blaues
pokémon die auch fliegen konnten nicht
nokia nicht nur wir das ding endlich auf
jeden fall also eine mischung aus lucca
und arktos noch ein bisschen und das ist
richtig richtig cool dann gibt es noch
einen job pinguine kann ich einfach
losfahren der sport nur wenn ich auf die
pickel de sie haben das letztendlich das
auf peaceful stelle verschwindet er auch
nicht kann ihn nichts bonn
ich setze jetzt einfach mal hin und weg
gehen jetzt angreifen wird kriegt er
auch vermissen rote augen denkt der
fischer und ihr seht schon der taktiert
mich mit so sachen die auf mich wenn ich
mal genau hinschaut seht ihr das weil
ich möchte ungern in den games null
gehen
jedenfalls kann ich dir dann auch
angreifen hier ich töte dich jetzt
einfach mal und dann euch ja kummer
es hat sogar geklappt ich dachte jetzt
komfort für effekt und das klappt ja
nicht aber der drop dann eigentlich
immer seine penguin schule kennen also
der wie fix you can um sie in seinen
katana schwert das katana schwert ist
ein schwert das macht +6 der manager die
ammann schwert macht +7 ich kann einfach
mal einen meiner pinguine umbringen hier
seht ihr mal dass drei schläge und er
ist einfach toll dass dein bruder diese
schule kennen kann ich zum beispiel auch
benutzen wenn ich einfach mal auf ich
glaube hier war irgendwo ein schwein da
kann ich einfach die schule kannst auch
werfen wenn ich jetzt mal treffen würde
hallo hallo hallo guckt da oder treffe
ich die machen zwar nicht so viel
schaden machen glaube ich nur einen
einen damage oder so aber es ist
trotzdem einfach cool mit schule ganz
andere leute abzuwerfen dann kommen wir
jetzt auch schon zum letzten pinguin der
hinzugefügt wird und zwar der flame
pinguin der flammen pinguin des bond im
netz und attackiert grundsätzlich auch
diese ok der attackiert grundsätzlich
auch zombie kidman und ihr seht schon
der sieht extrem böse auswendig den dass
beispielsweise auch mal angreifen denn
der dj
ihr seht die augen haben sich verändert
und der will mich an werken der fischer
aber ich gehe natürlich nicht zurück in
game und 0 weil ich hab nur noch wenig
leben ich boxe jetzt einfach mal hier
aus der höhe und ihr seht schon der fall
nicht fallen lassen
wir machen das ganze nochmal ich boxe
ihn ein wenig und da seht ihr auch schon
was er hat fallen lassen und zwar ist es
das hier red pinguins kinn und damit
wahrte moment steht mal wieder habe ich
jetzt mal wieder pinguin 1 gb seht ihr
hier eine rüstung zwar flame penguin was
den display die leggins und die flippers
und dafür benötigt man einerseits den
red pinguins kinn um das zu kräften und
man benötigt dafür hoffe ich mache das
thema ganz oben so ein bisschen aufräumt
man benötigt dafür dass hier und zwar
flame penguin scale ich habe ja gesagt
man kann sich ja diese rüstung verhaften
also der ablauf der modifikation ist ihr
holt euch pinguine tötet die macht euch
daraus eine rüstung seid mit der rüstung
gewappnet gegen diesen pinguin
dann kommt wieso sind hier zwei dann
könnt ihr einfach mit so einer schere
die auch aus den sachen von den anderen
pinguinen machen könnt könnt ihr einfach
hingehen und könnte den scheren
hallo hallo gibt immer deine sachen ihr
okay da habt ihr es gesehen also ich hab
jetzt den eingeschert
und jetzt habe ich diese sachen heraus
bekommen nochmal kurz um es hier zu
zeigen ihn mit einer schere mit rechts
drauf da kamen beispielsweise jetzt
wieder sachen allerdings müsst ihr
aufpassen wenn die das ganze game spielt
ihr seht schon die teile sind alle sauer
auf mich obwohl ich die kammer geboxt
habe das ist einfach wenn ihr die shared
ist zu zwei drittel passierte nichts
aber zu einem drittel und das ist
eigentlich erst selten der fall also bei
jedem dritten mal die leute die pinguine
da erschweren
da werden die böse das heißt wenn ich
hier beispielsweise mal einen spot kann
ich einfach hoffen okay geht es gut es
ging jetzt nicht gut aber ich habe
dieses geld bekommen und daraus kann ich
mir diese rüstung machen die ihr hier
schon sieht und diese rüstung besitzt
ein paar features und zwar
beispielsweise mit dem helm gibt es ein
paar mehr sachen die ich damit machen
kann mit ich will jetzt gar nicht alles
sagen also ich weiß dass ich mit der mit
der hose kann ich an land schneller
laufen mit den flügen mit den flippers
kann ich unter wasser schneller
schwimmen und alles ich habe die gerade
einfach weggeschmissen löcher was will
ich die anderen pinguine von mir der
mutter ich habe die ganzen die pinguine
helden einfach auf voll witzig aber naja
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal pin eingebe
fehle schon ich kann jetzt
beispielsweise diese schuhe mal holen
und die anziehen dann seht ich bin
allerdings an land ein bisschen
langsamer das ist normale jetzt
schrittgeschwindigkeit aber dafür bin
ich dann halt unter wasser wenn ich mal
da hinten hin gehen oder hier irgendwie
cd dann schon dass ich hier unter wasser
einfach so ein bisschen schneller
unterwegs bin ich denke das sieht man
mit dem bloßen auge das sich schneller
schwimmen okay ich merke gerade die
beeinträchtigt mich auch in der spring
höhe
ich komme mir nicht hoch gesprungen
richtig happig alter aber na ja das sind
halt diese pinguin schuhe
die ziehe ich mir jetzt erstmal aus
meinen tollen gegen den helm lasse ich
mir an und dann gibt es natürlich auch
noch ein paar andere möglichkeiten sie
können andere pinguine paaren wenn ihr
einfach weizen nehmt oder fische und
dann kriegen die so herzchen und ein
paar die sich untereinander sogar kleine
mini pinguine ihr können federn von dem
bekommen was kann ich euch dann auch
noch zeigen ihr könnt euch mit den
sachen von den flammen wie wir ihn
beispielsweise sonne repeater machen
oder ein pinguin wogen beim pinguin
bogen ist es so
der unterschied zu einem normalen bogen
es einfach ich möchte mich ab
ein alter es so süß komm ich mache
einfach ein paar brüder von dem und naja
der pinguin punkt ihr seht schon sehr
spannend extrem schnell und erhält 50
länger als der normale und ihr seht
schon ich kann hier richtig schnell
spannend einfach also das ist ein
richtiger op bogen das ändere mich
sondern die alten hero zeiten immer und
der repeaters einfach rechts gedrückt
halten keine sorgen mehr einfach alles
ab neuen jahr meine lieben freunde damit
war es dass auch eigentlich schon mit
der pinguins modifikation ich würde mich
extrem freuen wenn ihr für mich in
meinem kleinen kollegen leisten würde
weil es mal wieder nicht umfangreichere
modifikationen war aber auf jeden fall
nicht etwas was mein item hinzufügen ich
weiß ja nicht wie es bei euch gerade ist
aber bei uns ist gerade extremst es
unwetter deswegen hoffe ich man hat
keine blitze oder irgendein wind
zwischen dem hintergrund gehört ich
hoffe ich habe das irgendwie alles weg
gekriegt und wo es eigentlich ein
pinguin kollege kommt er hier noch mal
irgendwohin
der feldversuch vom himmel naja freunde
ich würde sagen wenn ihr weitere
modifikation wissen wo ihr sagt jordi
können sie doch mal vorstellen dann
schreibt uns in den kommentaren dann
würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr das
nächste mal dabei sein